hey up people have to vote I mean it
sounds sort of obvious I've been talking
about it I don't know how else I can say
it we are now learning about turnout in
the 2016 election and it is vile and
disgusting and yesterday we talked about
the blame game that happens after
elections and I said we can't blame the
results on racism
yeah lots of racist voted for Donald
Trump Donald Trump catalyzed and
coalesced the racist vote but there
could have been much stronger opposing
forces if people had actually voted
third parties some people blaming third
parties yeah gary johnson got some votes
he'll Jill Stein got some votes even
though much much less than Gary Johnson
but by and large the third party vote in
2016 helped Hillary Clinton not lose as
badly to Donald Trump
now I mentioned yesterday actually to
blame in part is the selection by the
Democratic National Committee in a in a
completely biased and unfair primary
process of Hillary Rodham Clinton who
was a flawed candidate and a candidate
with significant liabilities however
people have to vote and I told you
yesterday that we also have to blame the
fact that boaters didn't see this
election as an emergency this couldn't
be a sort of you know I don't like Trump
but I'm kind of busy on voting day and
you know I I don't really love Hillary
Clinton and and maybe I'll vote early or
I don't know I might not actually get a
chance to vote this should have been red
lights flashing
sirens blaring emergency stop everything
in vote but nearly half of eligible
voters did not vote in this election we
now have some data from the early
turnout rates this was compiled by the
United States election project and if we
look at early 2016 voting data forty six
point six percent of eligible voters did
not vote twenty five point six percent
of eligible voters voted for Hillary
Clinton and twenty five point five
percent of eligible voters voted for
Donald Trump and what that means is that
basically a quarter of eligible voters
decided that Donald Trump will be the
next president of the United States but
here is the most sort of devastating
part of this entire thing
let's look at swing state voting data
more than a third of eligible swing
state voters did not vote those that did
29.9% of swing state voters voted for
Hillary Clinton 30.9% of swing state
eligible voters voted for Donald Trump
they had as Pat mentioned earlier in the
show because we have an electoral
college system swing state voters have
disproportionate power relative to non
swing state voters and really this is
the most horrible part historically
Republican turnout was down slightly
Democrats didn't show up let's put up
the picture Pat of turnout in in past
elections in this one if you look at
Republican turnout from 2008 to 2012
Republican turnout went up but from 2012
to 2016 Republican turnout went down
meaning that if we had the same turnout
as in 2008 nearly 70 million Democratic
voters or in 2012 nearly sixty six
million Democratic voters Donald Trump
could not stand a chance
but Democratic turnout was so much lower
in 2016 that yeah we won the popular
boat barrel it barely not nearly enough
to win the electoral vote and corporate
media Pat keeps saying oh the silent
trump majority came out and won it for
Trump actually the fact that Democrats
didn't vote wanted for Trump 69 million
votes for Obama in 2008 Hillary Clinton
got 59 million votes in eight years
Democrats lost 10 million votes and as
we speak there are so many anti Trump
rallies going on around the country yeah
places like Portland in Miami major
cities across the country
you'd have to hope that most of these
people at least voted real I don't
subscribe to if you didn't vote you
can't complain but if you're now
activating and you didn't vote that's a
real problem
right I mean the first way you can be
politically active is to vote right and
you want to see how someone's so
unpopular like George W Bush or Donald
Trump can be elected president that's
how it happens and if ever that has been
proven it was in 2016 and it should be a
lesson by the way should anyone at the
DNC not be fired after what happened I
mean we could blame them for the way
they pre-selected Hillary Clinton we can
also blame them for the fact that they
they completely messed up their turnout
game and part of it is maybe people
weren't excited about voting for Hillary
Clinton but I don't know that anybody at
the DNC deserves to keep their job
convinced me otherwise I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman Warby Parker is offering a free
five day home Tryon to give you the
opportunity to check out their glasses I
personally wear Warby Parker glasses
when I'm not wearing my contact lenses
and I also started with one of these
free at home try ons of five pairs of
glasses you can get your free home try
on and support the david pakman show at
Warby Parker trialed comm slash TDP s I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show by going to Warby
Parker comm slash TDP s it costs nothing